mich hat heute ein thema aufgeregt und
zwar habe ich eine studie gelesen von
der konrad-adenauer-stiftung und wenn
sie das jetzt für einen werden sie zu
hause zum glauben das ist ein scherz was
die blonde frau da erzählt ist es nicht
denn jeder fünfte deutsche also genau
genommen 22 prozent der deutschen wollen
keinen kontakt mit es juli fahrern habe
es muss man sich wirklich mal auf der
zunge zergehen lassen dass also jeder
fünfte deutsche und möchte kontakt zur
suv fahrern meiden das ist aber leider
kein scherz und was mich noch schockiert
hat und die politische polarisierung in
unserem land den blick auf das klima
zeigt ist jeder fünfte gab auch an er
wolle die klimaaktivisten persönlich
nichts zu tun haben also 22 wollen mit
suv nichts zu tun haben und dann will
jeder fünfte nichts mit klima aktivisten
zu tun haben wir sehen also zwei sehr
strikte lager ich bin dafür wir sollten
sowohl mit suv fahrern als auch mit
klimaaktivisten kontakt haben können es
zeigt die gesellschaftliche spaltung ich
wünsche mir in der klimadebatte weniger
weniger ideologie und endlich mehr
pragmatismus
absolut richtig liebe männer also das
zeigt einfach dem zeitgeist wir sehen
die gesellschaft ist gespalten egal ob
fc bayern münchen dortmund egal ob
türken oder ungeimpft oder suv fahrer
oder lasten radfahrer sind auch
nebenkriegsschauplätze wir haben ganz
andere probleme eigentlich sollten die
brücken bauen brücken das miteinander
aufeinanderzugehen nicht nebeneinander
leben sondern miteinander leben und
momentan ist es nur noch aufgeheizt man
echauffiert sich ist eine erregungs
gesellschaft und man versucht immer den
fehler beim anderen zu finden es gibt
keinen diskurs mehr kann debattenkultur
mehr und kein aufeinander zugehen und
daran krankt unsere komplette
gesellschaft aber auch natürlich der der
der diskurs der pluralistischen
gesellschaft leider mache ich jemals die
gegenthese sorge also hätten sich aber
das habe ich mir so ein suv gekauft ich
habe mir wo die vermisste einer von
unserem tisch einig jetzt sagen
wenn ihr in diesem fall zum fehlen dabei
sei damit nicht so viel suv fahrer muss
ich die hand ins feuer legen euch auch
selber bilden nein also ganz gut aus
trotz vor euch so einem auto wobei ich
bin 44 angefangen hat dazu vor meine co2
bilanz ist makellos aber
eigentlich geht die these steht
natürlich die regel nichts wird
klimagipfel steht natürlich mit dieser
ganzen mit diesem getöse habe das ist
natürlich auch demokratie wenn das wir
jetzt solche debatten haben solche
auseinandersetzung und beim ihm vorbei
corona bei einem klima das finde ich auf
eine dass sich der phantastisch das sind
lebenszeichen der demokratie da wird
dann auch mal stilistisch überbordet da
ist man nicht die meine verliert man
etwas die nerven die contenance okay
aber dass wir diese debatte haben ist
doch etwas großartiges weil wenn man das
nicht hat dann kommen dann die
tv-experten und sagen so jetzt ist die
politikverdrossenheit jetzt gehen die
leute nicht mehr wählen sie gehen nicht
mehr abstimmen ich glaube wir haben
heute tatsächlich so eine reihe von
wichtigen weichenstellungen da gehört
natürlich diese ganze klimadebatte dazu
wie will man die lösen mit
marktwirtschaftlichem methoden oder mit
dieser kommandowirtschaft wie es bei
corona erleben was ist der richtige weg
wir wissen natürlich was der richtige
weg wäre
aber nur kurz ich das sind doch auch
gehörte lebenszeichen der demokratie und
vielleicht trauen wir demnach waren der
novitas glaube was der rutsche körper
seien absolut richtig wir sind wird
deutschland wacht gerade ein bisschen
auf nach diesem 16 jährigen schlaf kann
man fast sagen die mobilisierung schlaf
dornröschen johanna und dornröschen
schlaf kann man dornröschen angela da
war ja plötzlich streit galt ja
irgendwie als etwas schlechtes hatte man
fast immer auch der streit um das
richtige argument da wurde dann einfach
gesagt gewisse dinge sind alternativlos
haltet die klappe auf leute sagt redet
ich war darüber und legt euch wieder hin
oder setzt sich auf die couch es chips
und cola die wahl geheim gemacht hinzu
der zum ausdruck gebracht er hat also
abgeguckt bei der kanzlerin ihrer partei
war ein punkt noch einmal machen beim
thema klimaschutz ich glaube das was sie
sagen da ist ganz ganz vieles drin was
mich eigentlich stört an der debatte ist
dass sie natürlich komplett ideologisch
geführt sondern dass man eigentlich viel
zu wenig fakten schaut wenn ich mir
anschaue das ende dieses jahres drei der
letzten sechs und ende nächsten jahres
die letzten drei kernkraft meiler vom
netz genommen werden und dann bis 20.30
idealerweise in der koalition die sie
als mitte-links-bündnis bezeichnet haben
dann die kohlekraftwerke vom netz sollen
linksliberal kohlekraftwerke vom netz
gehen da müssen uns einmal nur anschauen
wie viel energie wir an einem tag wie
heute eigentlich genau von diesen
stromerzeuger bekommen wir haben heute
an einem zum teil sonnigen tag im
november der ist ein bisschen so nicht
gewesen ein bisschen wind stellen in
deutschland einen strommix gehabt und 13
uhr
68% konventionelle energie bedeutet rund
40 prozent kohle
11,8 prozent oder knapp zwölf prozent
kernkraft der bei 52 prozent der rest
mit gas aufgefüllt das heißt wir liegen
bei 68 prozent mehr als zwei drittel
konventionell und wir wollen uns dieser
ganzen dem größten teil dieser
stromlieferanten jetzt selbst beraubt um
dann zu sagen liebe polen liebe
franzosen liefert uns doch bitte euren
dreckigen kohlestrom euren teuren
atomstrom was auch immer das ist doch
lieber sie müssen in zwei rennen
aber dass wir euch pervers das ist
perverse energiepolitik ist und dass
eine verlogene debatte über die wird
nämlich mag ich ja da wir können über
diese energiefrage gerne diskutieren da
sind sie bei der cdu glaube auch richtig
aber ja zur atomkraft bisher nicht
gehört
sagen sie mal ich würde gerne zu der
wirklichen lage von denen er
zurückkommen das war die frage
haben wir eine zunehmende
radikalisierung in der gesellschaft auch
von scheinbaren minderheitenpositionen
also übertreiben wir an vielen stellen
mein plädoyer für große volksparteien
dass man sie auch noch retten darf weil
da die diskussion intern stattfindet und
nicht der ausgleich von wenigen kleinst
meinung manche sagen ja auch von
übergroßen minderheiten lauten
minderheiten die dann koalitionen bilden
aber die eigentlich nicht mehr die
breite der gesellschaft abbilden wenn
gleichzeitig die mehrheit der deutschen
sagt man darf nicht mehr sagen was man
denkt
dass das gibt keine korrelation zwischen
diesen beiden themen das eine ist eine
radikalisierung von minderheitenmeinung
und gleichzeitig eine mehrheit sie sagt
das normale leben darf man nicht mehr
ansprechen die normalen themen unter
anderem auch die frage wäre es nicht
sinnvoller gewesen
die atomkraft bei zu erhalten und die
und die braunkohle und steinkohle
kraftwerke abzuschalten wie man auf
schon
einmal saison aber als künftiger in der
rate kann einmal wissen wir werden unser
kopf stellen
viele professionelle
beeindruckt was er chef von austrocknung
war ich stehe da ein dämonischer gebombt
eilantrages turin einzige was wir
erwarten also heute es gibt das wirklich
durch einstimmig nicht ganz so es gibt
nicht nur eine radikalisierung der
minderheit nicht beobachte auch eine
radikalisierung des mainstreams eine
radikalisierung der etablierten politik
also wenn mir die leute die politiker
befehlen dass ich wenn ich ein
restaurant gehen hielt das ich glaube
ich zuerst zertifizieren lassen
womöglich noch einen war es auch immer
mich impfen lassen muss also körperliche
unversehrtheit zu haben sagen dann
brauchen wir natürlich auch eine
radikalisierung der etablierten politik
und diese radikalisierung
produziert natürlich dann auch radikale
gegenreaktion und da gefällt mir etwas
diese unruhe zu rhetorik diese
allerdings sehr überzeugende vorgetragen
haben die gefällt nicht nicht sogar uns
die blende für mich etwas die seite aus
vielleicht sogar die ursache dieser
radikalisierung der minderheit ist
vielleicht die radikalisierung der cdu
die radikalisierung der mitte
meine güte das ist aber viel um das
niveau hier dass
die politik der mitte stehen wir schon
noch aber die entscheidende frage ist
doch habe ich diese einzelposition alle
in einem parlament oder haben wir noch
volksparteien ich weiß nicht ob wir in
der schweiz noch volksparteien habt ganz
wir haben noch ein bisschen höhere
anteile aus die cdu habe ihr seid eine
unterbewertete aktie ihr kommt wieder
als ich bin ganz zuversichtlich nach
heutige sendung natürlich bin ich guter
dinge nein aber ich glaube die
diskussion innerhalb von organisationen
und wir erleben das ja überall wir haben
nicht mehr die großen verbindenden
gesellschaften das haben wir bei
gewerkschaften nicht bei kirchen nicht
bei parteien nicht sondern es bilden
sich sehr viele kleine individuell
gruppen und davon sind einige sehr laut
und werden sehr schnell
ohne wissen radikal und da haben wir aus
meiner sicht kein politisches
gegengewicht dazu dass diese dinge dann
auch in vernünftiger weise diskutiert
werden soll ich gebiet recht politik
läuft dann häufig dem mainstream
fünfte deutsches radikal weil es werden
wollen jetzt 22 keinen kontakt mit sbb
fahren da wäre jede für jeder fünfte ein
armutszeugnis für unser land nein ich
würde nicht sagen jeder fünfte ist
radikal aber wir erleben eine
radikalisierung von minderheitenposition
und dass man dann auch immer stärker in
diese blase rutscht und da auch gar
nicht mehr herauskommt weil man auch gar
keine anderen informationen mehr
wahrnimmt und die frage ist hab ich in
irgendeiner form ein gegengewicht um mal
mit den fakten die lage zu reflektieren
und zu sagen so und so sind die dinge
und dann wird man auch nicht gleich so
radikal sondern etwas etwas ruhiger